[MUSIC PLAY]
SIMON HADE: When we started Space Ape,
it was definitely smaller.
We were only 12 people.
Now we are 55.
TOBY MOORE: Building mobile games was something new for us,
but we had a lot of experience building games in general.
We only had to learn very quickly.
That's why we had to use it as a learning platform
while we made a video game for our users.
JOE REABURN: We all discussed ideas
of what makes everything a fighting strategy game fun.
And we're really simply crazy about Japan.
And we love Japanese and Oriental fantasy.
JOHN EARNER: "Samurai Siege" is about building and fighting.
You build a fortress.
You make it stronger.
And you try to defend it against other players
trying to steal resources from you.
And you fight against them again and steal their resources.
SIMON HADE: Our ambitions for "Samurai Siege" were pretty good
modest when we started with it.
We initially introduced it to Australia and New Zealand.
Then we had a grace period of about six weeks.
JOHN EARNER: Within two weeks of making the game available in beta,
We were already making $ 10,000 gross per day.
And so we have made it available worldwide.
And within a month we had about 300,000 people daily.
And monthly about 1.5 million people played the game.
And by that time we knew
that we are bitter.
Nowadays we make about $ 55,000 a day.
Weekends are rising.
On our most successful day, we made $ 220,000,
which is a small number at the same time as comparing it
with some of the biggest gaming companies that exist,
but really good if you are 18 or 24 months old
and you start getting started with one
of your first titles.
That's why we're pretty excited about it.
SIMON HADE: Android's share of our revenue increases.
That's 50%.
Much of the growth stems from our focus on Asia.
I think 10% to 15% of our income comes from Japan alone.
JOE REABURN: We always planned
"Samurai Siege" to take to Japan.
We just wanted to make sure we did it right because we
knew we had one chance with one of the world's largest
game markets.
JOHN EARNER: We've been to Japan for four months
on the launch.
And the game was basically available everywhere else.
JOE REABURN: One of the reasons is
that we spent a lot of time locating our game
and to be ready for culture; a translation of many
to have high quality.
JOHN EARNER: We've learned how users see ads.
We learned what they think of the game.
We were in beta in Japan for a month to test it.
SIMON HADE: That's why we had to find local people
what would keep our game, what
could be ambassadors for us.
And after we made it available, they were really
the voice of our players in Japan.
JOE REABURN: The alpha and beta test feature
in the Google Play Developer Console is a good approach to follow.
So you can pick a group of people yourself
associated with the Google group.
And then you can get user feedback.
You start to see how your game is in the real world.
We wanted our marketing material in the Google Play Store
Looks like a local Japanese company does it
created, which are actually more exclamation marks
and mean cute characters.
We used our internal Japanese staff to tell us what it should look like.
And we put it together.
And in the end it really looks cute, really exciting.
TOBY MOORE: Google Play is a great platform
to develop with.
I really enjoy the high repetition rate and how
Thinking about bringing games to the Google Play Store,
and working with the partnership team.
JOHN EARNER: The experience with Google Play is great.
We found it about half
heard from us and half of us are business.
Although the success we have achieved so far is how exciting,
is the thing we really look forward to, that next step,
what lies ahead.
I think what keeps people in games,
is always the excitement of working on the next game
and see that it is made available.
And so I look to the next one.
[MUSIC PLAY]